Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Merci.
Bonsoir à tous.
Je suis ravie de pouvoir
partager avec vous,
ma passion pour l’artisanat d’excellence
et de vous partager aussi pourquoi
je pense que le talent de la main humaine
est si important au temps du digital.
J’aimerais vous raconter mon expérience
et aussi vous montrer des objets uniques
créés par l’humain pour l’humain.
J’espère pouvoir vous démontrer
que l’artisanat d’excellence répond
profondément à nos besoins de relations,
de contact, d’authenticité,
mais aussi tout simplement de beauté.
Dans un monde où les machines
nous rassemblent de plus en plus,
nous nous posons parfois la question :
« Est-ce que les machines arriveront
un jour à nous dépasser ? »
Nous apprenons chaque jour les progrès
des intelligences artificielles.
Nous demandons à ChatGPT
de nous écrire un texte, un poème
à Dall-E de nous créer
un tableau, une photo,
et des objets s’impriment
aujourd’hui en 3D
sans avoir été dessinés
par qui que ce soit.
Je ne suis pas contre la technologie,
mais je me pose la question :
« Qu’est-ce qui fait donc notre différence
en tant qu’humain ? »
L’artisanat d’excellence
nous donne des réponses,
car il concentre ce qui nous distinguera
toujours en tant qu’humains.
Les objets vraiment créés
par l’humain pour l’humain
créent de l’émotion par leur beauté,
par leur exclusivité,
par leur individualité.
Ils sont plus que des biens matériels.
Un objet artisanal d’excellence
nous raconte l’histoire
de la personne qui l’a façonné.
Il nous parle de sa passion,
de son savoir-faire.
Il communique aussi cette recherche,
toujours pour la perfection et l’harmonie.
L'objet possède ainsi une âme donnée
par sa créatrice ou son créateur.
Je l'ai déjà vécu si souvent.
Nous sommes touchés quand
nous connaissons l’histoire d’un objet.
Quand nous pouvons échanger
avec l’artisan qui l’a façonné,
quand l’artisan nous explique
son savoir-faire, sa technique,
le temps passé à créer,
les défis qui ont été dépassés,
l’objet devient une extension
de la personne qui la créé.
L’artisan et l’objet
deviennent indissociables.
Et c'est bien cela qui nous touche.
Certains d’entre nous commencent
à se fatiguer des objets de luxe.
Nous trouvons les mêmes sacs à main
à Tokyo, à Londres, à New York,
certes de grande qualité,
mais si standardisés, si rationnels.
De plus en plus de personnes
cherchent donc à s’entourer
d’objets avec une vraie histoire
et de belles valeurs.
Un mouvement culturel global vise
à revaloriser les savoir-faire,
le fait main,
à les rendre désirables
pour les générations futures.
Ce mouvement est important non seulement
pour protéger notre héritage culturel,
mais parce que nos descendants
auront autant besoin que nous
de relations humaines.
Vous vous demandez sûrement :
« Mais comment pouvons-nous
définir un objet d’exception ? »
Après tout, pouvons-nous déterminer
ce qui est beau ou pas ?
C’est évidemment subjectif,
mais malgré cela,
les recherches dans le domaine
de l’artisanat s’accordent
sur des critères d’excellence
tels que la tradition,
le territoire, la créativité,
l’authenticité, la compétence, le talent.
Ceci pour permettre
une sélection plus structurée.
Vous vous en doutez,
un certain savoir-faire horloger suisse
remplit bien ces critères d’excellence.
Nous sommes
dans ce magnifique musée ce soir
qui retrace
notre riche histoire horlogère.
Ici, nous pouvons parcourir les origines,
les traditions du monde horloger,
mais aussi être témoins de son innovation
et de sa créativité.
Cet écosystème est bien ancré
dans le territoire de l’Arc jurassien.
Il est intimement lié à la transmission
des savoir-faire entre humains,
au sein d’une culture bien particulière
où horlogers, ingénieurs, designers,
mécaniciens, décorateurs,
travaillent ensemble
pour créer des montres exceptionnelles.
J’ai moi-même découvert
l’horlogerie à la Chaux-de-Fonds
quand j’ai fait un échange Erasmus
à l’Université de Neuchâtel.
Cela m’a fascinée.
Je suis rentrée à Londres pour terminer
mes études avec un rêve :
je voulais travailler
dans la haute horlogerie.
J’ai donc déménagé ici
pour mon premier emploi
chez Girard-Perregaux.
J’ai dû m’habituer à la neige,
à la grande rigueur, à pointer à l’heure
et pas une minute en retard.
Mais quel bonheur !
J’ai passé des journées avec les
horlogers, les admirant travailler,
assembler de minuscules composants,
à admirer la complexité de leur travail.
Mais j’ai aussi appris que
la prouesse technique ne suffisait pas.
Une montre devient un objet d’exception
quand elle est enrichie par des gestes,
par une décoration que
seul l’humain peut réaliser.
La montre ne donne pas seulement
l’heure, elle a aussi une véritable âme.
Comme l’horlogerie,
l’artisanat d’excellence ne peut pas
rester dans la répétition du passé.
Il doit évoluer, se développer.
Bien sûr que sa durabilité, sa valeur,
sont liées à l’expertise,
à l’excellence de la réalisation,
mais aussi à sa pertinence
pour l’esthétique d’aujourd’hui.
Sinon, les objets ne resteront
que des reliques
dans une reproduction
d’un héritage bien passé.
Pour y arriver,
la transmission et la valorisation
des savoir-faire sont clés.
C’est pour cela que je travaille
aujourd’hui à des projets
qui rapprochent les savoir-faire anciens
avec le design contemporain.
Aussi, pour montrer aux
jeunes d’aujourd’hui
que l’artisanat peut offrir
une vraie voie professionnelle.
J’aimerais maintenant
vous raconter trois histoires
où le monde du design vient
à la rencontre des métiers au Portugal,
l’un de mes pays d’origine.
Emmanuel, au centre,
est un designer français
qui est convaincu qu’il faut
valoriser les savoir-faire locaux.
Il essaye de travailler
pour créer des objets contemporains
dans le respect de la tradition.
À ses côtés, voici David et Pedro,
des artisans ébénistes qui travaillent
dans une fondation d’art décoratif,
spécialisée dans les meubles d’époque.
Ensemble, ils ont créé ce coffre,
sculpté entièrement à la main,
à partir de différents types de bois.
Les artisans ont pu mettre
en exergue leurs talents,
dans un contexte
tout à fait nouveau pour eux.
Voici Sam, lui aussi un designer français,
qui a travaillé avec Ricardo.
Ricardo est un maître artisan dans
une manufacture réputée de porcelaine.
Ensemble, ils ont créé ce service
de table peu commun.
Cette terrine en forme
de tête de sanglier,
avec ses décors peints à la main,
est une pièce pour moi tout
à fait surprenante et ludique.
La dernière histoire me tient
particulièrement à cœur : José.
José fait des arrosoirs en fer blanc
lorsque Christian,
designer à succès allemand,
découvre son atelier au nord du Portugal.
Ensemble,
ils ont créé ces tables d’appoint
en laiton poli
qui combinent parfaitement
la réalisation traditionnelle
avec un design actuel.
Ces quelques exemples -
il y en a tellement d’autres -
démontrent selon moi
comment l’artisanat de l’excellence
peut se tourner vers le futur
et s’ouvrir au monde.
Nous arrivons à la fin de ce voyage.
Je vous ai montré de magnifiques objets
créés par de talentueux humains,
de La Chaux de Fonds et d’ailleurs.
Des objets qui nous fascinent,
qui sont uniques,
qui ont une âme.
Ils nous touchent non seulement
par leur beauté, mais par leur histoire.
L’artisanat d’excellence
répond profondément
à nos besoins
de relation et d’authenticité.
Au fond de mon cœur,
je suis donc convaincue
qu’il est absolument indispensable
au temps du digital.
Et, par nos mains, nos doigts,
nos têtes ou nos cœurs,
nous sommes tous liés à sa valeur
et à son futur.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)